particularly this week
with the international day of
remembrance of the victims of slavery
and the transatlantic slave trade
i strongly agree with my father the
prince of wales who said in barbados
last year
that the appalling atrocity of slavery
forever stains our history
i want to express my profound sorrow
slavery was abhorrent
and it should never have happened
while the pain runs deep
jamaica continues to forge its future
with determination
courage and fortitude
the strength and shared sense of purpose
of the jamaican people
represented in your flag and motto
celebrate an invincible spirit
jamaica is a very free and liberal
country
and the people
are very expressive
and i'm certain that you would have seen
the spectrum of expressions
yesterday
there are issues here
which are
as you would know unresolved
um
but your presence gives an opportunity
for those issues to be placed in context
put front and center
and to be addressed
in as best as we can
but jamaica is as you would see
a country that is very proud of our
history very proud of what we have
achieved
and we are moving on
and we intend to
attain
in short order developing goals
and focus of our true ambitions
as an independent
developed prosperous
culture